so normally I would get into the office
for around 7 A.M 7 15 because obviously
our Market is Germany and they're one
hour ahead um and between 7 and 7 30
I'll plan my day so
um I'll use Trello
um or like a diary and then I'll work in
Sprints so we'll have like four Sprints
and yeah like between seven seven thirty
I'll be planning my day
um I'll have like a to-do list so I'll
know exactly what I need to do because
that to-do list would have been done the
day before and I would obviously have an
idea of what I want to do from the day
before it's just about like implementing
them in the morning so I would plan it
out change anything if anything happened
overnight and I'll set up my Sprint for
like eight to ten would be a lot of BD
so that would be BD
um and then 10 to 12 will be candidates
resourcing and then lunch will be from
12 to 1 and then one to three uh BD and
then three to end of the day back into
resourcing so I know it's quite vague
but
um
it works it works and it's the perfect
balance of getting 50 50. the
recruitment mentors podcast is proudly
sponsored by VIN cherry and the
award-winning Source breaker